Add some of Avengers: Endgame's crew to the
list of people who weren't thrilled with Thor's
husky new look.
In a recent interview with Empire magazine,
the flick's screenwriters Christopher Markus
and Stephen McFeely revealed that the Thunder
God's new appearance didn't sit so well with
some of those who were on the production's
set.
In case you're one of the six people who hasn't
seen the film yet, be advised that spoilers
for Avengers: Endgame follow.
You'll recall that after Endgame's five-year
time jump, Professor Hulk and Rocket set out
for New Asgard to track down Thor, who had
dealt with his failure to prevent the Decimation
in a rather unhealthy manner.
"You should've gone for the head."
Specifically, he had spent the previous half-decade
drinking enough beer to drown an elephant,
playing Fortnite, and growing the type of
gut you rarely see on superheroes.
Many fans felt that Thor's obvious depression
and new, portly physique were being played
for laughs, although later scenes treated
his fragile mental state with sensitivity,
allowing it to play into his larger character
arc and making the near-immortal god that
much more relatable for the audience.
According to Markus and McFeely, a few unnamed
crew members took issue.
Markus told Empire,
"There was a sad moment where it was like,
'We've got this gross, disgusting body for
Thor now.'
And then they unveiled it and it's just kind
of like everybody else's body here."
"That's a nice way of putting it."
McFeely added,
"There were many people on set who were angry
at us about doing that to Thor."
McFeely, however, implied that the on-set
anger wasn't necessarily because they felt
that Thor's condition was being handled with
a lack of tact, but because the screenwriters
had seen fit to send the character on his
downward spiral at all.
Markus agreed, saying that it was simply a
brutal shock to see just how despondent the
mighty Odinson had become.
"I don't drink tea."
"What do you drink?"
"Not tea."
Nobody, not even the God of Thunder, could
put away that much beer without packing on
a few pounds in the process - and that it's
not like Thor went on any kind of crash diet
before jumping back into the mix to take part
in the Avengers' most important mission yet.
He would still test the structural integrity
of the Megingjord, if you catch our drift.
"We just gotta load Tony's old hulkbuster armor, the prototype for Cap's new shield, and
The Megin...
The megin…
Thor's magic belt."
Markus defended the decision to keep Thor
beefy throughout Endgame, saying,
"I like that heroes come in all shapes and
sizes.
[Thor] comes from a tradition of guys like
Volstagg, of a big, ass-kicking fat guy.
There's no reason that he has to slim down."
We hope that the character of Thor continues
to be explored in interesting and unexpected
ways, as he may be the only original Avenger
who will continue to be a presence in the
films of Phase 4.
Endgame's conclusion saw him heading off into
the cosmos to find new adventures with the
Guardians of the Galaxy, and Tessa Thompson
- who portrays New Asgard's new ruler Valkyrie
- recently let slip to the Los Angeles Times
that he might also very well be the first
MCU character to get a fourth solo flick.
Of course, it wouldn't be too surprising if
the God of Thunder were to shed all those
extra pounds before his next appearance, but
one could simply chalk that up to there being
no decent beer in space.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.